weird i gotta be a little nosy orl let's  just set the record straight all the  rumors you know you know the rumors Nick  Jonas you're gonna Nick Nick yeah I  guess I'm this carpet you're asking no  I'm yeah yeah that bad is that bad he's  great you're not gonna tell anything to  talk about this brand is really nothing  attack Ali much yeah not after he sees  you in this dress oh there's any  tightness sweetheart night vanetti  diamond Kate stunned in a custom nude  colored two-piece gown by michael kors  showing off those killer abs look at her  dress or dresses already night under  dresses sort of naughty why would gold  is not going on well I you naughty and a  good way how the flirtatious flirtatious  yes I love it we did we did we like we  had a couple different dresses and I  wanted we've had such a great year  together and i love it why i say this is  kind of naughty for my goal yeah